sont les défendre la princesse de mes
rêves retenus captifs par un mauvais
sort au creux d'une source proche sawa
me guider et j'avais prêté serment sur
l'eau vis de la délivrer et puis le
temps aussi s'est écoulé
j'ai pu les paie une canne
c'est ainsi que la légende de la source
vu le jour et toujours cette narration
de jean carmet inoubliable gravé sur la
bande son du spectacle une bande son est
essentielle avec des moments de textes
et de musiques intense à vous faire
battre le coeur de la peur de la colère
l'émotion qui donne des couleurs
supplémentaires la magie une bande son
qui dirige tous mûri champions et le
responsable de la régie son
en général il se cale soit sur des
phrases musicales pour entrer ou sortir
200 soit sur des textes ils savent qu'à
un moment donné ils doivent sortir des
coulisses parce que ils vont entrer en
scène
donc pour eux ce sont des repères
importants parce que c'est ce qui va
permettre les entrées et les sorties de
scène de manière magique parce que les
gens on les voit les acteurs on les voit
et la scène suivante c'est d'autres
personnages qui sont là attention les
chevaux vont rentrer
quand on sort vous longez surtout élèves
ils viennent de semblançay ou d'ailleurs
depuis 1989 ils furent des milliers à
grossir les rangs des bénévoles pour
yann ils sont 600 par an adapter leur
vie on rit bouddha cynophiles sylvia zoo
et la présidente de l'association
jacques debout et marécages
ce que vous voyez derrière moi c'était
un marécage et donc on a tout organisé
pour un spectacle qui s'est passé le 17
juin 1989 et on a reçu 1500 personnes
donc ça nous a un petit peu monté à la
tête on s'est dit ouah c'est super on a
dû bien joué et on a dit bon ben on
continue au début on était 60 pressant
et aujourd'hui on finit la saison n'est
on a 600 adhérents puisque tous les ans
on a des recettes une association donc
tous les ans on adhère et on finit la
saison entre 550 et 600 personnes
ici personne n'a d'étiquettes sociale et
les générations se croisent se
transmettent tour à tour guichetiers
comédiens techniciens ces enfants ces
femmes et ces hommes - point commun
offrir chaque année durant l'été une
heure quarante cinq mille histoires
comme dans un film mais en vrai avec
cette magie du spectacle vivant si
proches dans une étroite relation
acteurs spectateurs ou le temps nous
transporte hors du temps
[Musique]